we're not a sports show but we are going
to stick with hoops and sometimes the
hoop quarter is a great way to send a
message we begin this hour with a
life-changing Act of compassion on a
basketball court it's part of our
kindness 101 series with Steve Hartman
where we share stories that are built
around kindness and character today's
lesson is sportsmanship Steve and his
kids show how sometimes letting someone
else live out their hoop dreams can be
more rewarding than taking the shot
yourself
good morning I'm here with my daughter
Meryl to discuss the importance of
sportsmanship across the way let's toss
it over to my brother Emmett at the
dictionary desk good morning Meryl
sportsmanship is treating people with
respect and generosity in a gamer
contest right it's basically everything
we teach in this class just in the form
of a sport that's a good way to put it
because I think a lot of kids get in a
game and they think oh now I don't have
to be honest or or caring or empathetic
all I have to do is win but you should
be the same person in a game as you are
in real life
over the years I've met a lot of good
sports who subscribe to this belief
including this one the best example I
have of a really great sportsmanship
and I know you guys get tired of me it's
little things coach Peter Morales of the
Coronado High School Thunderbirds in El
Paso Texas makes no qualms about it he
has a favorite on this team Mitchell I
need you I need you to help me out with
my coaching tips Mitchell team manager
Mitchell Marcus has a developmental
disability one two three but he far
surpasses everyone here when it comes to
Love of the Game he's this amazing
person that our basketball team loves
being around
and because basketball is that important
to it on the last game of the regular
season the coach told Mitchell to suit
up
just wearing a jersey was enough for
Mitchell but what he didn't know was
that the coach planned to play him
and so it was with a minute and a half
left coach Morales put in his manager
and just started hearing Mitchell and
mid so
but here's where the fairy tale fell
apart although his teammates did
everything they could to get Mitchell a
basket each time they passed him the
ball he either missed the shot or like
on their last possession booted it out
of bounds turning the ball over to the
other team with just seconds left
did you have ever imagined what happened
next I did I could not not at all
what happened next happened on the
inbound the guy with the ball there was
a senior at Franklin High School number
22 Jonathan Montanez I was raised
to treat others how you want to be
treated
what Jonathan did was yell out
Mitchell's name then threw the ball
right to him one of the most memorable
turnovers of all time
[Applause]
it wasn't the game-winning shot when the
buzzer sounded Coronado had 15 more
points than Franklin but Jonathan's
assist in Mitchell's basket did change
the outcome decidedly
play any game with this much
sportsmanship both teams win
nine years have come and gone and the
story has only gotten better
Jonathan montanyas joins us now hello
Jonathan hi there how you guys doing
we're doing great safe to say that
turnover changed your life definitely
for the better good what happened after
so after the whole ordeal happened next
thing I know I'm getting texts and
emails and fan mail and Mitchell's also
getting text emails fan mail but the
biggest call came from the chancellor of
Texas Tech University the chancellor at
Texas Tech got a hold of the video that
you guys broadcasted out offered me a
scholarship and I gladly accepted it and
this was a full ride scholarship yes you
wouldn't think just being someone at
least being kind would get a scholarship
in a sense maybe there should be more of
that I mean kudos to that guy for
recognizing that this is the kind of
school we want to be a school that
rewards kindness definitely what did you
study and what do you do now I actually
studied Kinesiology and right now I am a
coach and a teacher here in Lubbock so
you're a coach now
yes sir I take it this is probably one
of the lessons that you teach definitely
um just following the Golden Rule can
actually just lead you to uh New Heights
honestly all right well thank you so
much for your time and we really
appreciate you talking with us
bye bye
That's my kind of sports hero and to be
like them just remember when you win
don't gloat when you lose don't pout and
when you play
don't ever leave your compassion on the
bench we'll see you next time until then
stay kind
[Music]
of Eve you in Maryland
don't ever leave your compassion on the
bench right but don't you like the
message that that president of that
University yeah just off of One Clip
yeah that kid a scholarship yes now we
got to find we have to call Steve find
out what happened to Mitchell how is
Mitchell doing I want to know I don't
know what it is about those videos they
always make me want to cry as soon as he
hit that shot I got goosebumps I started
welling up because those are all the
people we're trying to be honestly when
you look at that's why when I see a
story like DeShaun Watson I I look at
that message that that sends and I look
at the message that that sends and it
really does make me think who are we who
do we want to be yeah it's a great day
for that whole High School Community
they're rushing for sure he's on their
shoulders beautiful yeah yes